let's just break this down real simple
trying to get hoity-toity we can make
eight to ten minutes work in a short
film this is what we know how to do
let's make a movie that's like ten eight
to ten minute scenes in a row it'll look
like a feature and and that'll be our
first movie and so we set out to write
the puffy chair which was a movie that
we kind of reverse engineered I guess to
be something that we could afford to
make you know we wrote for what we call
the available material school of
filmmaking I was a musician and I had a
van I lived in an apartment my
girlfriend at the time Katie who is our
star in the movie she had her own
apartment and and she was from a small
town in Maine where her dad was a lovely
black bag doctor who everybody loved and
we could get things for free he's here
right there sitting in the front row
Thank You papa appreciate that and ands
really okay let's write this movie and
fit it in all these spots you know and
then we wrote it and we send it to our
agents and and a couple of them were
like tell you what we could package this
movie for you and we're like so that
sounds cool what does that mean um and
they're like you know put like some kind
of you know young movie stars in it get
you a couple million dollars to make it
and and then we started talking to
people and they were like yeah that can
take a long time to package movies and
we kept seeing these heartbreak stories
of people like just waiting forever to
get their movies made and so we asked
our parents for $15,000 to make the
movie and and they gave it to us and so
we just went ahead and and shot it
ourselves and there was this time where
we were doing because it was hard it was
painful we weren't making any money
we're like maybe we should have just
tried to make this in a more traditional
route but it kind of worked out so well
for us that we you know almost to this
day plus or minus we've kind of stayed
with that ethic but to be clear this
movie the puffy chair that I've heard
textbooks tout as a game changer was
literally approached as oh please God
let us make a movie that doesn't suck
let's stack all the cards in our favor
so that we can do something that doesn't
suck please please don't suck so as
you're putting your parents gave you the
money was this something
you went and asked them for it or I mean
most parents are like you want to do
what you want to do what yeah I'm an our
parents were incredibly supportive of us
I think that it was a little bit of an
easier decision on their part because
we'd had three movies at Sundance
already and we had a little bit of
traction but we would not be you know
sitting here if it were not for our
parents and and that support and we you
know we really encourage parents to do
as much of that as they can it's really
really helpful um we also were like you
know we were editing and you know
killing ourselves for years and I mean
you know we definitely come from this
mentality and we still are dealing with
it which is we have chosen to be artists
we have no right to pause or to play or
to order the $8 entree you only the four
dollar entree I mean you know we lived
on street pizza and peanut butter and
jelly and you know and we just ruined
ourselves so I mean hurts we're like
please take the money stop killing
yourselves the mentality was very I
don't know it's hard to describe sounds
self-congratulatory right now but I mean
you know it's just we were of the
mindset where we were killing ourselves
for a decade trying to make this thing
happen so I think everyone who newest
was like yeah please make a feature I
mean the truth is is like the reason we
made the puffy chair is that Sundance
called us and they were like guys we've
had enough short films from you please
make a feature and in a weird way we
followed that method of like waiting for
people to ask like we were living in
Brooklyn and we were living in Austin
and we were being flown out to LA a lot
and it wasn't until like Hollywood made
it clear to us that we were going to be
making a living here that we moved here
you know it wasn't until Sunday and said
make a feature dude you know and it
wasn't until tons of producers were like
can you move out of the fifty thousand
dollar range of filmmaking please that
we even started to do that